i feel like from the conversations that
i've had typically most young people
like are leaning towards like i'd really
like the idea of being in the office
more yeah how are you saying that
because you speak to a lot of young
people and have young people in your
business yeah i think they want to feel
part of something i think you know the
people that we're hiring they want to
come into the office they want to learn
they want to see it because a lot of
time it's blind faith in recruitment a
lot of time because you're doing
something because someone's telling you
to do it yeah but until you see it
happen sometimes you go oh i get it now
so i think they want to be able to go to
the gym at lunch time yeah come in at 11
because they've got something to do i
think they want the flexibility but they
definitely want to be together my job is
to create an environment where you can
do that i'm all for make the decisions
that suit you right the recruitment
mentors podcast is proudly sponsored by
vincerie and the award-winning sauce
breaker